gang christmas came early this year
cause the ru garbage special is on
youtube right now yeah guys go share
with your friends hit them up in the
group chat tell people who aren't
familiar with the show this is a perfect
way to introduce them check it out it's
a good time a lot of laughs thanks for
watching love ya welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is r u garbage
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they're good to be classy we're after
just a big old piece of trash yeah i'm
your host holy coming at you on a chilly
day very cold here in the northeast and
today's upstairs she got the space
heaters out trying to keep her plants
alive
she don't want to ruin the crop this
year if you know what i mean
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me we've got a little company in
the building he is the ceo of ru garbage
he is the second international
businessman here in the studio oh i
don't like that me being the newly
appointed i bought a couple of things
over there i made some purchases bought
some magnets and stuff but give it up
for kj it's mr kevin james ryan god damn
it hey gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true to roof cooking baby check
dispatch check out the splash over there
on youtube the ayg spash it's a
compilation of uh our last year on a
road a little behind the scenes stuff
shout out to tape bomb for that and
obviously patreon.com which is cooking
you sign up you get bonus content uh
episodes ayg hard feelings live stream
the whole nine yards check it out
absolutely have a nice quick shout out
speaking of which to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good give it up for t-bone
mcbuggins toby mcmullen good to see you
pal what's up good to see you guys
thanks everybody who's watched the
special reached out and you know we all
worked real hard on it and we're [ __ ]
we love you thank you yes absolutely
love you guys and we absolutely
absolutely adore and love our very
special guest that's here with us today
he was supposed to come and visit with
us around the holidays because he's
[ __ ] family but because of the
omnicron we couldn't have him in uh but
he's here now we love him ladies and
gentlemen on his way down to pitchers
and catchers in clearwater [ __ ]
philly more of a catcher
hi pitch a [ __ ] philly superfan ian
finance everybody
cousin ian
is here cousin ian's here good to see
you family thanks for having me i
couldn't be happier to be back i had a
gift for you but i left it at home
classic cousin classic i left it in the
uber you got to be you got to be the
last [ __ ] guy they invite the [ __ ]
family holidays i'll tell you that the
first guy right i'm going to find you to
give me the wrong address
ian why did you forget us this year some
whitman's
half eaten whitman a half-eaten sampler
cvs candy for the fellas
that's right and an anniversary card
good to see you buddy how are you i am
fan [ __ ] tastic couldn't be better
very grateful for every day i got and
every day that's coming my way and i'm
very happy to be here man this guy just
got out of a meeting
hey jesus
[Laughter]
feeling good in the neighborhood through
the one true lord christ
i saw the video you're [ __ ] jumping
around uh with who's that the mighty
boss stones no
pie tasters what did you just do you got
a little corned beef in your teeth no i
had a mustache in my mouth and i pulled
it out
sometimes they get long they get my
mouth i gotta yank them out i pull i
pull the ones out from the side
there it is it feels good right it feels
so amazing
amazing it was the pie tasters cat bite
9 30 club iconic rock venue in dc i
don't know what the hell he was talking
about
your old pal
toppers
real big in sheboygan yeah was this the
grammys what are we talking about again
the pizza ovens getting away you guys
perform it i will
not have you besmirch my friends in sky
hey push the soup will ya
rock venue in calzones
boy's got a hot chocolate the number one
hot dog in dc
there's a painting of italy on the wall
a picture of john travolta behind you
soprano impersonators
ah
it was awesome man
this is a band do you like yeah the pie
tasters and cats i got one too
[Laughter]
i'm a big fan too i'm big in europe
and in america
and in this room
uh they were great man it was awesome
cat bite great ska band from philly i
went out i sang with them i danced
around it's [ __ ] awesome dude better
not let the insurance investigators see
you [ __ ] hopping around the stage
like that looking fit as a fiddle i know
i know shout out to my osteopath and
physical therapy
helping me out you will not get paid
yeah no he's very good on ious
do you pay at the doctor yeah you wait
and get the bill and i paid the doctor
you do yeah wow i got it i'm all right
i'm doing it by eater's tickets
he's not that far off to be honest
what are they called the pie tapes yeah
they seem like an awesome band yeah
they're great fantastic they're great
they're fantastic dude they were the
first ska band i ever saw live when i
was like 14 at the trackadero and then
now i opened for them in dc it was
pretty cool so they must be doing great
come a long way huh
listen fellas
don't make me well i got a gift for
knuckles yeah what's with that
oh yeah he's got bricks brass knuckles
what do you what's going on under de
blasio turned this down to [ __ ] i'm
taking it back
i stopped a woman from getting the [ __ ]
kicked out of her in brooklyn ever since
then i've got the knuckles to take care
of myself really yeah it was gnarly who
was this i was [ __ ] down on on third
i was the one hitting her
i stopped myself from beating up a woman
i wanted to hit her when i did it
i could have i would have taken her for
sure yeah yeah she would have gotten it
stole her breast knuckles and i left but
uh
no i dude it was gnarly and uh a couple
comics got popped that's your last
gnarly for the episode by the way what
are you talking about
just said
that with the pie guys too much sorry i
know yeah well you know have you ever
been close to tragedy that's a good song
great song
isn't that every song
[Laughter]
they're great
i have a feeling you don't respect scott
that's the impression that i get
not a big sky guy for sure that's the
door that you leave through
so tell us your batman can't fit through
what
[Laughter]
it's good all right it's quick it's good
no dude i was riding my bike and i i saw
what was this recently yeah about maybe
two months ago okay it was no no it was
before i hurt my back so probably like
october i think i was riding my bike and
i saw this girl getting chased across
the street and i didn't know what it was
and i thought that it was like just a
couple play fighting you know she was
like help help he was like get back here
i was like that's flirting yeah he's
shooting at her
ah new york in love am i right folks
he's got a knife i'm like wow they
really care about each other
so dude i i go a little and i turn i'm
like wait a minute and this guy is field
ball field field goal kicking this girl
on the street jesus it was [ __ ]
domestic situation or just a random
attack i didn't know him personally
actually all right i didn't say like hey
did you guys fighting over the bill how
do you guys know each other originally
yeah yeah yeah where are you guys from
i crowd work
my material's not strong
i'm more of an attitude man you're
visiting huh so uh i intervened and uh
what'd you do grab him i didn't get
anywhere close physically i was he
pulled out his mace so i
i gotta let the bear spray at the house
yeah yeah yeah i threw some whitman's at
him and then what do you know i hate
chocolates and left she's dressed like
dog to bounty hunters kid
you gotta get off the ice i took out a
bible and i started screaming at him no
from far away i was like get the [ __ ]
off her and he got and looked at me and
she got up and ran away nice yeah and
then uh he came after me and
i think she ran that way yeah yeah yeah
i'll help you uh no dude i just so
what'd you do thank god he goes who the
[ __ ] are you
ian finance follow me
hi animal69 on twitter twitch and
instagram
bye guys on wednesday
sopranos prima vaulted with sam roberts
he goes who the [ __ ] are you and uh i
didn't have time to think so i said uh
i'm a concerned citizen oh my god
about to get his ass kicked
i'm a guy who made a mistake
and now good for you we had some words
and then you know it just kind of died
down there nice went along my way there
you go yeah now you're [ __ ] now
you're ready dude the [ __ ] up thing is
she i saved her and she didn't even
thank me that's always a weird situation
i think
no i chased her down the stream beat the
[ __ ]
get back here
you don't thank me
it was uh her mind was obviously in
other places well well that's good you
saved her it was great cheers to you
buddy thank you
[ __ ] not all heroes wear capes that's
right but they do wear shitty philly's
jerseys and jewelry
you really got me something i got you a
gift bag we got you a gift for christmas
your cousin ian oh my god i feel so bad
about the whitman
[Laughter]
what do i got in my pocket
leave the ferret in there please
no rodents there's a no rodent policy
two halls cough drops on a gerbil i
legit have tums i'll give you
all right here it is
no way there you go custom made
custom-made custom bernie's hat look at
that embroidered bernie's beef i love it
thank you so much this is great
i love it there you go hell yeah cover
that hairline now
he's thinking what the resale value is
it's gonna be on ebay by the time he
gets out of here
facebook marketplace is coming at you
he's gonna be in the facebook group i
have this in a boba fett for sale
you guys notice these things are missing
i got a team
i got a producer for you we call them
buttons
uh that's great i got a bernie shirt
that i wrote i know
i know i posted a picture with it and
you're like i want one
thank you that's that same one i was
wearing so you know you might want to
watch it yes i do see a bit of uh some
lights there's some rogue there's some
rogaine stains in there
[Laughter]
so what did you do over the holidays how
was your christmas man incredible yeah
amazing me and my gal we drove to to uh
i had that road gig in dc in the 26th
so that means it doesn't like we oh the
okay
what it was with the bear yeah yeah okay
i thought you were just talking about
like we knew your schedule wasn't wait
that was a gig wasn't that you just you
going to a concert no i opened okay
sorry how long did you do i did like 10
before the first band then before the
second band i went up to what songs did
you do
i sang sunday morning and no doubt cover
with cat bite did you really yeah it was
awesome and then for one of the pie
taster song he had me sing and i forgot
the lyrics so i was just going la la la
la
but what can you do you know you are a
strange bird cut that
so the 26th
me and my gal drove down to delaware in
the morning saw my mom on the lawn do a
little gift exchange you know omicron
you gotta you know post christmas
yeah after christmas gift exchange yeah
it was nice the worst i don't go i don't
really go home on christmas i do it
later
christmas is just when everything's on
sale
you get the catch on the 27th real cheap
no
well because i got a birthday on the
31st too
so it's like you know you're banging out
all in one shot
so we went down saw my mom
took a train down to dc
had a great time
on the launch day where'd you stay uh we
just went to delaware in the morning and
then took a train to dc because that gig
was on the 26th how'd you get to
delaware drove her car so we dropped the
car off at my mom's went to dc real fun
had a great time next day
went back to delaware saw my mom got the
car drove up to a yurt
in saugerties outside of woodstock
stayed at my buddy's yurt for two days
amazing
i was making fires in the snow wood
burning stove we went to the church bob
dylan got married in incredible time
yeah nice dinner nice up there this time
of year incredible we found walking
sticks we're walking around strangers
are saying hi some guy invited us to his
property to meet his dogs you can't beat
it
amazing
no just nothing nothing nothing nothing
i was going to make a rude comment but i
decided not to how big was the yurt
which we know what a year it is now yeah
who grew up in a yurt i'm a woman she's
alive she was a dome oh
a geodesic dome geodesic dome yeah
you're thinking of my homie who lives in
a dirt a yurt now you know me that lives
in the dirt
he does have a couple of those he got a
couple dead friends sounds like a bad dr
seuss ball
the man who lived in the yurt
by shel silverstein i will not have
cable here
there was a man who had no money
he moved to the woods and sold his honey
we had to poop in a place that wasn't a
toilet it was funny
wow
cut that
so dude the yurt was awesome man we love
how big is the yurt the earth they had
yurts at [ __ ] casey and robbie's
wedding probably the size of this
[ __ ] studio yeah that's like a big
great guy the guy lives there full time
no no he's got two yurts oh he's doing
well for himself it's the lead song he's
got some
yeah i started following him on
instagram he's great nice dude yeah kid
i got the album love that song
um what are you doing sorry shout out
wes you're the best shout out wes good
looking kid too
let me know about this yurt future
weekend plans dude he uh we could go up
there that'd be a great time doing a pod
from the yurt your pods
yeah and also i don't know if you could
fit uh we could build one around you
we can we can make one out of your
t-shirts
got my own year
[Laughter]
what's inside the yurt it's awesome dude
you walk in you know there's like a
little table wood burning stove couch
and then it has like a fridge the bed
yeah fridge
um uh countertop little area for cups
and coffee and stuff cotton mutton
what i don't know
what is a cotton mutton
what is a cut he thinks
mutton is a meat and you're cutting
yeah i come home from work early she's
in there cutting mutton with the mailman
i said listen dolly you're out on the
streets
have you know cutting mutton when i'm
here
uh
yeah so it was great little bedroom
really nice
awesome very cool time dude it's so i
love going to the woods
in the morning the sun's coming up you
just get some coffee cigarettes out in
nature
oh my god it's crazy that you know the
lead singer of the lumineers yeah how
did that happen by the way he saw me do
stand up at greenwich comedy club years
ago and dug
yeah they couldn't get into the cellar
so they went down to greenwich parker's
got him and yeah i know right and all
the con there was like 12 people there
and every comic was going up and they're
like oh this is so bad no one's here
blah blah and i'm not
i didn't have time to say all the words
so uh it's called words madison garden's
a restaurant your family got kicked out
of it
when you're here you're not family
so i go and uh i'm like are you really
in the lumineers he's like yeah i was
like look man i was just scabbing in
high school i get it and uh god
should you know the pie tasters
had a good time and we talked afterwards
exchanged numbers then we've just been
buddies ever since i remember you
brought you brought them to a show at
new york comedy club that we were both
on did not introduce me yeah i did nope
standing right there not introduced no
this is pre-ayg though no now you got a
little cachet when you're walking yeah
did not him and his girl got out of the
cab
did i i was standing right there in a
rush because they got there late now we
need to get him in yes i remember that
disney iced me no i didn't don't ever
[ __ ] say that i wouldn't i see you uh
oh you're gonna beat me up knuckles huh
get them
[Laughter]
put them in a yurt
you better be careful bro ian's gonna
get dykstra in here [ __ ] tune you up
oh yeah speaking of another famous
palette we've talked about it on patreon
uh but ian got us in a love triangle
with lenny dykstra and his booker hey i
help you out talking about not taking a
no for an answer yeah what happened i i
don't know what happened oh here's
literally
there's nothing to describe ian more
than we tweeted who do you want to see
on the pod or whatever if i hear a pair
of cleats walking to the door i'm
jumping out the window
i start smelling popcorn and hot dogs
can i tell you what happened
from my point of view you guys go who do
you want on the pod and i go lenny
dykstra
and
you're tagging everybody that's her
audience thinking hey why not so hold on
yeah so i go oh atlanta you can't win
the tickets you work for the radio
station yes
i like that in finance
tweeted from schmie and five buddy lenny
so then it turns into
uh
oh and then he i go yeah lenny we'd love
to if you're out there me you know then
he texts me he texts both of us we're
getting headshots we're getting we're in
a photo shoot and he you text us yeah
you guys are in the middle of a boss
photo shoot
olin mills don't worry
we only have we only have the studio for
another 12 minutes we got to make it
happen
i'm on foley's shoulders back of the
seat a lot of women the dog won't look
at the camera
halfway up the ladder
um
and then you you text us hey can you
talk i literally respond no and two
seconds later you're calling me hey i
can get him on the phone i talked to the
booker maybe we could do it as a package
deal me and lenny yeah what the [ __ ] i'm
like i want to talk to him about how he
[ __ ] me over 2008 so i go listen
i don't yeah that's what we want yeah
you pissing him off in our studio yeah i
wouldn't hate i don't know
you getting your [ __ ] beat out of you
wearing a lenny dykstra jersey
i could get down with that
nails knows how to handle them
getting beat up by your hero that's
great so well so then you turn out you
turn me over to the booker you talk to
the booker then the booker starts
calling me texting me and calling me
going i got lenny he's on the way it's
here he's here why yeah i didn't know
that all i know is i talk to the guy and
he goes look uh yeah i'll call him and
see what he thinks he's gonna probably
ask for like a hundred dollars
i gotta say i get 20 when he's here he
goes he goes i gotta say he's not well
he goes i gotta say he's not well he's
kind of [ __ ] up in the head but it'll
be good you know for whatever and i go
all right i'll talk to them see if it's
all right meanwhile i don't know he's
going to you i don't know i don't think
he's like i know him through other
businesses yeah and i don't know that
he's calling you and he's like i got
lenny in a van i got no clue about it he
wasn't saying it was just it was just
like either way he needs a place to wash
up
you know he's gonna stay in place for a
couple of days until he gets his head on
straight until a couple of things hey if
anybody asks me who's with you all week
he'll do it but he needs an alibi for
the 12. he's a good guy but keep him
away from the cold cuts
i'm going to i'm going to bring him by
and drop off some fake movie tickets
anybody yes you were at the cinema
i was at the rangers game
with dijkstra so was he they were away
that week
you're all hemmed up in federal court
jeez now you got to roll on lenny then
they put you in the same cell now he's
pissed at you
yikes
no thanks i love dykstra
and i wouldn't you know i don't you know
yeah
so what happened what do you mean he
came in we had a great time what do you
think happened he called me a couple of
times i just told hey man we're not
interested yeah we killed the phones and
disappeared for a couple of weeks
so the lenny blew over
hurricane lenny coming in kirby let's
talk about helix mattresses helix
mattresses ain't they the best you got
one i want one you don't gotta hang out
in some mattress store like a bazook
nope you go online you take the quiz you
tell them how you sleep and they're
gonna straighten you out yes guys it's
fantastic the good folks helix were nice
enough to send us one and then we liked
it so much we upgraded to a king same
one twilight series okay that's what the
test gave us the two minute quiz easy
peas i mean i mean abroad took it
fantastic um he looks awesome but don't
take our word for it uh they were
awarded number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazines
helix has been recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as the go-to solution for
improving sleep there you go just go to
helix.com garbage take the two minutes
sleep quiz match you with a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life 10 year warranty you get to
try it out for free for a hundred nights
risk free they'll even pick it up if you
don't love it but you will helix even
has financing options uh and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is not too far away this is it helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com garbage one
more time helixsleep.com garbage do it
gang this podcast is sponsored by better
help yes good folks who better help want
you to know if you got something that's
standing in your way of fulfilling your
happiness they can they can actually
help you it's not a self-help line it's
not a crisis line it's licensed
therapists that are available 24 hours a
day for you to talk to yes you'll be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be available
locally if you live in a smaller town or
a little more remote area yeah the
service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
at any time send a message to your
therapist you get a timely thoughtful
response sent back to you you can
schedule weekly monthly video calls
phone calls whatever you want they're
there to help it's easy peasy
better better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they'll make it easy and free to
change therapists if needed
um special offer for ru garbage podcast
listeners you get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com garbage one more
time that's betterhealth.com
garbage do it i'm always i was a big
dijkstra fan as if me too growing up in
philly
i got the dalton jersey on right now
shout out to dutch i got a dalton story
if you want to hear it okay my god what
are you hanging out at the locker room
what are you doing
how are you seeing all these guys i've
lived a life
in 93 okay you were like 11. what are
you talking about
in 93 i went to philly's baseball camp
right make a wish and uh you were
working at a mcgirks and philly yeah
kirk they came in you know
can i tell another thing real quick you
know i i shaved my head when i was
younger i was i was like maybe eight or
nine right i went to a phillies game and
i was right by the field and it turned
out that it was like a leukemia type
thing mm-hmm
and they invited and i know a good deal
when i see them
they invited all these i'm not gonna
tell them no
it's lying by omission when they started
hooking me up to the chemotherapy
machine i got a little worse i did have
an iv bag but sure they invited all
these kids as leukemia on the field and
they were walking by me and they kept
pushing me to go out going come on don't
be scared and i just was like okay
and i went on
there
the other kids are all weak and coughing
you're running the bases and [ __ ]
tracking down fly balls i gotta tell you
i feel great
i take out a kid at second base
you go and cleats up
so uh anyway
uh 93 i'm at philly's baseball camp
prior to that do you remember when the
phillies used to be able to like get
down to the front throughout the innings
you know yeah you started out with the
bad shots and you end up whatever yeah
so we did that the third ball dad moved
that's what that is yeah and so i dalton
like struck out or he like didn't do
something this drunk guy's behind us and
he's heckling he's yelling blah blah
blah and i was like stop that i like
took up for darren dalton and he goes
hey kid you ever get a chance you get
down to the field and ask him about his
friends jack daniels and jim beam and i
was like that means so i go to philly's
baseball camp 93 darren dalton shows up
he does like a uh clinic type thing and
then he has a question and answers with
all the kids shows you how to buy a
hooker
and uh pulls his dick out i raise and
and afterwards he's doing a signing
right
so uh he was like holy [ __ ] you lived
you look good
wow chemo works
so i we were all taking bets you were
gonna
we thought you were the link weak in the
chain
[Laughter]
hell of an immune system on this skin
i'm saying that so i raised my hand to
ask a question and uh they call on me
and i go
um
darren
how are your friends jim beam and jack
daniels
and he goes excuse me and i said it
again he goes kid where are your parents
they left me weekly and i go i go my
mom's at home and my dad's in heaven oh
god
and they stop the question and answer he
doesn't do the autograph session and
later they just hand out cards to
everyone
you were that kid you did say heaven all
the time
not not oh my dad passed away he's at
the north pole with santa
he's up in the clouds if we take a plane
high enough can we see him
my mom's at work and my dad got taken to
the farm dude ian's been ruining events
since he was seven
a wake of a wake of social awkwardness
follows in a round
hey dutch i hear you cheat on your wife
what's the deal
can i smell your fingers
[Laughter]
when did you shave your head uh this was
i'd say summer 93. wait why what does it
have to do with the chemo or the
leukemia no because i had it shaking i
had a show
i thought i had leukemia so they put me
out of them she's like a dirtbag forest
company yeah
[Laughter]
so there i am in the jail at the
veteran's day life is like a box of
chocolates and no one's looking and i
need him
[Laughter]
you are something else what can you do
huh
you're the first kid in the fake-a-wish
program
shout out dutch who's now in heaven he
would wish for two more wishes
i wish for unlimited wishes
kid i'm not a genie i'm john cena
contractually i have you beat i'll talk
to your lawyers
and now for my first wish
wish for more wishes
that's great
[Laughter]
that's a smart move
you wish for more wishes yeah if you're
an eight-year-old grifter
you wouldn't wish for more wishes
you can't limit it to making a wish
oh i thought you meant like a genie yeah
well that i mean that's as like every
eight-year-old that
i would wish for three more weeks yeah
and then wish for two more things and
then three more weeks i wouldn't get
greedy big dick be able to fly
unlimited juice boxes foley's flying he
can't get up high because he's fat he's
smacking people with this big dick
sorry about that kid needs a bigger
propeller
there's too much drag on that boy you
need more wishes buddy
[Laughter]
wish for a helicopter above him to hold
him
[Laughter]
up yes of course my move with the genie
would be i want to limit wishes but
that's never the thing you can't wish
for unlimited wishes i'll talk always
there's always that's always that caveat
let me tell you
you got enough cash things can be done
talk to dutch adult yeah yeah
damn yeah
all right should we do a couple of
queues
from the gang this is a heater
holy hell gang as you know when you sign
up for the old patreon yeah got a
question right on the air uh-huh and now
you have
celebrity e in finance here that's right
he's dressed like a [ __ ] bat boy
no that'd be one of my wishes
i always wondered who those kids were
you know what i put up with what do you
mean no for uh [ __ ] was his name sean
bowers shawn but he was one of the best
you gotta have it in with the team right
you guys gotta yeah you gotta be like a
kid of the groundskeeper he got no i i
forget how he got in he got in early or
of a fake disease
shave your head
yeah hide in the dugout they can't find
you
don't touch me every leprosy
from like seven to like 20 he was the
batboy 20 yeah
he's still a bad boy yeah and i think it
just so you don't be able to get you
don't start playing you shouldn't be
able to be in bad boys they don't they
don't upgrade you to closer you
shouldn't be a bad boy if you can
legally drive to the stadium i get it
it's a good gig and then uh then they
moved them in the like in the clubhouse
like that's awesome because they got to
the point where like hey but he said
they would [ __ ] whack him out i don't
think it pays but he gets heavy tips
like at the end of the year yeah
like jim tomy would tip him like 10 g's
or something really what they got it
tommy had a nice dude that is awesome he
sounded like he paid for collet like he
did it he did it literally from like how
did he get the gig i don't know would
you do it now
be it philly's batboy
one game
for one game yeah of course no the whole
season next year the whole scene you
can't do stand up
no
i can't i think you get you get to open
the you get to open the game can i can i
make them laugh at the locker room
you're whipping them with tails yeah
yeah hey fellaini
he's got his dick tucked in
hey boys
hey harper check it out
i heard it's your birthday
[Music]
yes the answer is
yes oh god
i would do it if you could promise we'd
all be best friends
oh
man that's too [ __ ] funny all right
god damn
[Laughter]
it's been a minute since we had you pal
it is no i'm happy you've been a while
yeah missed you i mean we've all been
busy i miss you guys too yeah chatted a
little bit over the holidays we got to
talk to each other yeah it's good it was
nice
catching up i left you all on reddit i
was like hey happy birthday or whatever
happened i don't like that by the way
and then he was like how are you feeling
feel it because he had covered and we
were checking
we were talking i know i was bit i was
on vacation with the family yeah i was
doing you know i don't like that you
switched over staring at me like you
hate me what no i'm having a good time
he hates you though yeah he does hate
you but we pay him to smile i offer you
concert tickets you say no but you come
in and you order them around like you're
jackie kennedy i didn't order [ __ ]
what'd i order
uh somebody's fart no i did and i didn't
think you'd smell it so i made a scene
there's a track
attached to dope i picked the fight
it smells like beefaroni god you're
gross what are you eating school lunches
penny vodka for breakfast teddy vodka
oh my god
i had three dollars worth of breakfast
this morning digging through the digging
through the pennies is the best part
yeah
for breakfast penny vod delicious
penny vodka it's cheaper
you're over there guzzling the sauce
i was thinking about how nice it was of
kevin to wish you a happy birthday that
must have felt really great for you to
hear from him on your oh i didn't wish
you i heard from toby when's your
birthday january 1st no december 29th
you called me this bozo left me now ice
me wait i didn't call you the wish happy
birthday i didn't know it was you
oh i didn't pick up because i was
sleeping but i thought that's why you
called me
[Laughter]
you got to remind them who's balls
around here too you know i can't just
say there was a problem with the clip
you misspelled chris jenner by the way i
didn't know it was your birthday happy
birthday happy birthday happy birthday
yeah well don't be that's a [ __ ]
little kid move how to [ __ ] a woman am i
reading your [ __ ] file i don't know
when your [ __ ] birthday your friend
say something he's your friend i'm not
what do you guys spend enough time
together you can't wish your kid a happy
birthday it's not that who brings up
when it's my friend oh my birthday
friend's eating frog i wish a kid a
happy one huh who you've been talking to
um
how would i know when his birthday is i
knew now in hindsight i did know it was
a rant we've made fun of him
for being in that limbo week yeah yeah
we talked about it on an episode very
recently yeah
you're you're a new year's eve birthday
i am that is the ultimate trashiest yes
got in before that for the tax break
[Laughter]
keep all my five dollars sometimes 27
days premature because i was a thinker
gotta get in there
i was three we were just bothering her
too much i was three pounds eleven hello
three pounds eleven ounces it was a
preemie yeah you could hold me in the
palm of your hand two and a half without
the glasses i was
i was three pounds 11 ounces because
since birth i've been down
see who knows that 11.
that's garbage
who knows how much they weighed when
they came at it with it when you're that
little you got to know it what do you
mean how much were you
i think i was normal but i'm not saying
you've never been normal pal
how do you know that you were three
pounds whatever because my mom talked
about it all the time growing up you
know exactly the marriage you were born
12 16 pm miracle miracle i was i
shouldn't have lived i had jaundice i
was in the hospital for a month
yeah
i kind of had i i had some issues in the
beginning too
yeah these wheels almost didn't get off
the ground really your poor mom her
[ __ ] knees must have been in her ears
that had come out big irish potato head
coming out
uh it was a rectal birth
i came out the back door
speaking of the back door i just let
another one out come on man i can't help
it broadcast in here i know well if i
hold it in my stomach hurts
why do you think i got the tums
look i'm older i'm falling apart i'm
embracing it i'm loving it wait i know
you were you were having issues you you
you were an issue
i was a candidate for sids
what's up sudden infant death syndrome
gotcha how are you a candidate for that
uh good grades per card
what's your family vote on it
well i was early in the i was leaving
the polls for a while
grassroots campaign that's how
i had to sleep on a board only get on a
wooden board upside down like what are
you a [ __ ] vampire yeah
with scoliosis like a skateboard ramp my
uncle build it
yeah wait a minute wait what yeah i
swear to god i still do it by the way is
that why your head's so big all the
blood rushed down and just stayed in
[Laughter]
all the cells gathered at the top
like a tomato on the vine
wait
back this up they had to strap you to a
board wait will you step upside down
you're like
yeah my head i believe my head had to be
below my feet
here let me look it up that's terrible
that's absolutely terrible do you have
any pictures
of you in the board catching hair now
you hanging like a bat as a [ __ ]
three-month-old
drop your bottle you're screwed oh my
god
i don't know i don't know i just i uh
i forget i don't know i've never really
um
those babies are all sleeping normal i
think your uncle i think your uncle was
just out of work
and that kid's gonna need that kid's
gonna need to sleep upside down
yeah that kid's gonna need a roon
goldberg system to sleep
uh i don't that's rude goldberg
goldberg's the skater pants of extra
wood left over from the bar
[Laughter]
upside down i don't think upside down
put that boy in a birdhouse quick
you got an attic you're gonna need one
yeah it needs more food in the feeder
you need some newspaper down hope for
the best it'll be all right
boys gonna make it
time to move them in get a pair cage
i gotta talk to my mom i've never really
asked my mom about that that's terrible
that's very serious yeah
the one time i did i brought it up and
she's like started like i was like all
right we're moving on oh my god oh you
poor thing thank god you mean i'm a
survivor you and me look at that what
well don't worry about it
what what would you have again i had
jaundice
i was 27 days premature i had to be an
incubator and then uh the i see that
they left you in a little too long
i got a little overclocked i'm under the
hot lamp at roy rogers
you're a day old this guy yeah
you were in your mom's womb like i hear
some attention out there
why is no one looking at me
someone look at me
[Laughter]
i get it i'm gonna come out early and be
sick
i can't i was he came out dancing
[Laughter]
your mom evicted you i'm here for some
pie tastings
oh my god kate what do you know about
the gang over there bespoke post the
spoke post love them box awesome are you
familiar with it because it's pretty
cool stuff some would say top of the
line top of the line yeah it's state of
the art cool guy stuff gang if you don't
know about bespoke post box awesome you
got to get yourself involved get it once
a month absolutely fantastic right now
it's the winter i can just imagine it
could be grooming stuff it could be home
bar stuff it could be outdoor stuff
camping camping cool threads
maybe some cozy stuff yeah yeah they
sent out do it right we've said it a
thousand times they sent us such cool
[ __ ] i got a knife that i opened up all
my amazon packages with
they sent us the uh the duffel bag
that's right over there we take on a
roll with us i got a tumbler i love it
so to get started you take the quiz at
box of awesome.com your answers are
going to help them pick out the right
box for you they release new boxes every
month across tons of different
categories easy to sign up cancel at any
time each box only costs 45 bucks
the cream 70 worth of gear inside yikes
yes uh and there's 90 of the stuff is
from small businesses so it'll be
supporting small and upcoming brands
there you go uh you got twenty percent
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome dot com enter the
promo code garbage at checkout
box of awesome.com
code garbage for 20 off your first box
do it talking about my fave the butcher
box butcher bags oh yeah i still got a
meat full of freezer a freezer
i don't know what i'm saying i'm all
jacked up on ground beef yeah because i
got plenty of this guy's got bacon on
the brain ah man whole turkeys wild king
salmon salmon salmon sent you some
alaskan salmon dude you know what gets
me is the steak tips i'm a big steak tip
guy we have them out right now they're
sitting in the sink defrosting getting
ready to get cooked up at the foley
house butcher box is a subscription
service that takes the guesswork out of
finding high quality meat they source
all their meat from partners with the
highest standards of quality no more
food searching the grocery stores hunted
for 100 grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken wild-caught seafood and
more wow uh every month butcherbox sends
a curated selection of high quality
meats right to your home free shipping
in the continental u.s uh no antibiotics
no added hormones all that kind of stuff
out the door for a limited time butcher
boxes offering new members a great deal
for the new year sign up at
butcherbox.com a-y-g and you'll receive
the ultimate new year's bundle in your
first box this deal includes ground beef
chicken thighs pork butt that's seven
pounds of meat added to your first box
for free get this new year's bundle
before it's gone by going to
butcherbox.com ayg now back to the show
yeah and you were a normal birth i
believe so yeah you don't remember know
how much you weighed
at normal normal weight
i don't know the exact it's weird to
know the exact i agree i was born three
pounds nine nights that's like your
mom's sitting down and telling you that
too many times yeah someone never told
me that [ __ ] what do you think yeah
that's crazy yeah why do you think i am
this way
hey [ __ ] wasn't too normal in the fire
dance household pal
huh getting told how much you weighed at
birth all the time you wore your bronze
shoes around
that should have done way better no i
object
to the court did you have that bronze
shoes oh yeah my got my shoes bronze
bronzed what yeah you didn't have that
no she probably pawned them yeah what do
you think wait why did you get why don't
people do that when babies pass away
yeah no in like remembrance yeah it was
just like what your
your family was
what's the thing
you have something here
we'll be right back
what's
what's the thing where you got atomic
first sports what's the thing where you
put it out in the universe and make it
happen bitcoin no
when you oh like an aspiration a goal
like you know like they're like like a
vision board yeah no your family put the
bronze shoes on the vision board all the
time all the money put you on a three in
the pool
like an old time mobster
i was late on the vig
stop eating all the crackers fatty
he's sleeping with the fish
he's sleeping with the skimmer
ah that's funny
all right oh jesus christ
sorry
she coughed up a frog
snail shell pops out
now all the kids in my family all had
their baby shoes bronzed that is a trash
move what are you talking about you're
bronzing shoes yeah i don't mind golden
and and in our handprints no
on what
like plastered no oh i got the hammer
not han solo yeah of course everybody
did it but no no bronzing on the ship
she probably couldn't afford it i don't
know what to tell you what do you
do you still have the bronze shoes
you know buried in the backyard you know
it's trash
box
and i swallowed the key
you're gonna have to gut me if you want
these shoes financed
there was a hair it was a mule for brush
shoes
now put it someplace
you want to know what was trash or my
mom did before i got braces she spray
painted your sneakers
oh god
t-bone
why don't we bronze that joke and put it
in the hall of fame as [ __ ] oh and one
count back at it let's go all right dude
my mom got a plaster mold of my teeth
before i got braces because they were so
[ __ ] up geez and she would show them
to people when they came over jesus
yeah yeah
yeah because i had big old buccaroonies
they did it for that's how they mo
that's how they figure out the braces
like they do right right but she has to
keep it
that's a little yeah it's a little
strange yeah i'm trying to set you up
burn your
teeth leave that thing in a fire let me
see dude if i can get the mold and bring
it in you're not bringing that i don't
want that i don't want that anywhere
near the building it's not my teeth
this is post braces what i'm looking at
i got great teeth on the top
i got a great tooth out there
man i got good tooth
my tooth is fantastic
ian's wonderful he has amazing tooth
i think the one's all premature
[Laughter]
i got my toothbrush he's got a couple of
preemies in there and one's over
he had three sets of teeth because he
came out too early he's like a shark
[Laughter]
stinker
[Laughter]
what would your mom do for you on new
year's for your birthday
cause that thank god it wasn't christmas
christmas is a tough look yeah
born christmas day blow up balloons you
know
what's so funny about that blow-up yeah
birthday balloons she's well you went to
work through at the party store my mom
in eighth grade threw me a surprise
party and she got the wrong banner and
said a happy birthday happy retirement
wow that was just cheaper
that was not on purpose she took that
from work
gary in accounting retired oh dude
here's a trip for my 18th birthday dear
ian enjoy
arizona here's a watch
a half a day old cake
i got the cake on discount it's in the
trash you throw them out daily
uh
for my 18th birthday we had a party at a
bowling alley in newport delaware
directly across the street from the
halfway house i would have to live in
like five years later oh my god isn't
that funny wouldn't it be great if one
of those bullets yeah that's hilarious
crystal ball
right now you're writing a memoir what's
going on what i should
me and
me and lenny dykstra tales of a dirty
delaware doozy the ian finance story
a friend of me
the friends of my dance that guy owes me
dijkstra
what does he owe you yeah he told the
story one of the uh previous um uh on
center city podcast no you told it on
here as well yeah you went to his hotel
or something like that yeah and i did a
bunch of work for him he was supposed to
come give a speech at my school when he
never did and then he ghosted me okay
yeah yeah so we don't want that being
rehashed here yeah this isn't a [ __ ]
mediation that's like when george comes
in with a stained sweater well no i need
you guys i need backup you guys are here
yeah
i'm not fighting lenny
that guy would [ __ ] us up dude no he
wouldn't he's [ __ ] mental exactly
those old ball players nah yeah dude his
name wasn't his name was nails yeah but
dude that was when he was at his peak
right now he's an old roided out [ __ ]
lunatic he could [ __ ] knock him out
in a heartbeat i don't think so i'll box
him you're nuts oh will you jake paul
you're boxing
i'll let the pay-per-view guys know you
don't think i could you were just
walking around with a cane for like nine
years yeah my osteopath fixed me up you
don't think that i could it's gonna be
your corner man once i
your cat is your cut man
can my girlfriend come
that's a deep cut
that is a deep cat
you don't think hey ian i killed my
roommate i need help burying the body
can my girlfriend come
she's a fun
she loves murdering people hey we're
going to do an intervention for foley we
really think it's getting out of hand oh
great can we get over that again
she loves fat pieces of [ __ ]
you don't think once i get this hernia
thing checked out
i could beat up dykstra no
listen
you never start
beating somebody up with one second
procedure
listen after rehab listen once i get
these gallbladder stones taken out i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up
six
buddy
eight weeks after i heal i don't want to
pull my stitches and no feces let me
tell you something when i get off
dialysis dijkstra you're going down
dude he was gonna get my goiter he would
go right for your [ __ ] like a spider
monkey what are you talking about yeah
your nuts would be awesome
so it's a win-win for me
ian's also the ring girl
he's tucked in again
he's carrying a card remember this one
from 93.
in the ring dancing around in orthopedic
boxing shoes
one's higher than the other
he's got one of those club flinches
i have a lift in my shoe right now oh my
god
i'm five seven
oh oh this is hurting my ears premature
huh
let's get these in a couple more minutes
like a bad gingerbread man
we were going for over easy we got
sunny-side up with this one
[Applause]
get some toast for this kid i could beat
up dyches face
without a doubt
i don't think you could not happen and
we're not gonna find out no shout out to
mr dyker and the dijkstra organization
yes we love these big fans
this is a big show what let's get back
to lenny he could be a fan of the show
about lenny dykstra being pissed off man
let's hang
on the show
next episode ayg yeah
all right we got a couple of minutes
left here let's let's crush through a
couple of questions
i know that's great your crazy cousin
ian
um all right let's see here
this one i've never thought of but it
i've done it it's a tough look this is
from keaton ever take your shoes off in
the bathroom before taking a shower what
so you've worn your shoes you've been
wearing your shoes in your house and
then you go into the bathroom decide to
take a shower so that means you take
your clothing off and then put your
shoes back on
what are you talking about i think your
brain's a little medium rare
what are you talking about no you're
well you're dressed like this yes and
you walk into your bathroom to get to
take a shower so you deep you take your
clothes off you just said
you ever take your shoes off to take a
shower you didn't say all your clothes
that was implied ever take your shoes
off in the bathroom before taking did
you ever have to have your you ever had
then the question would have been you
walk around your house naked in your
sneakers
yes
which is why i was confused
i wear slippers to the shower oh
very nice big fan where do you dry off
at do you dry off in this in the shower
or do you get out and fully what do you
do or do it do a half and half i in the
shower i uh
do the top half get the water off and
wait with your hand or the towel with
with the hands you get the initial layer
of water off you get you get the heavy
you get the hair so your towel's not
soaking wet yeah idiot
and then you get out your towel off
and then uh you know i gotta do the wrap
around on my head because i have curly
hair
so then i i do that in the bedroom and
then i get ready put your makeup on and
uh
grab a closet you know grab a clutch
do you guys oh do you guys have your
clothes waiting for you no when you get
out of the shower in the army
yes you got to make sure your gig line's
straight
you guys don't know about you lay your
outfit out like you're going to school
yes wow yes and i facetimed my mom to
make sure
let me see the teeth again no dude i
take out i take out my what is my socks
my underwear my shirt my pants put it on
my bed so then that way i get a shower
bing bam boom put it on i could do that
on occasion sure how long does it take
you to get ready
uh
my whole process is half an hour
wow yeah i mean if i'm taking the car
wash but still
still 30 minutes depending on who's
working the hose that night
depends if he wants the armor all or not
[Laughter]
sometimes they get detailed
no i'm so so i can take that's what's
like tunes in the shower
if i have to lay i i give myself on the
half an hour i give myself a hand out
the door to out the door yeah half an
hour i'm i mean that's a nice you're
missing some crevices no that's a nice
shower we got 127 hours going on in
there that's a nice shower that's a
scrub that's a couple that's a couple of
songs in the shower i'll do a couple of
songs
i'm one song in the shower i can be i
can be ready that's sky that's quick
yeah i can be done 15 minutes
i'm half hour out the door really yeah
i gotta do the road game what are you
doing
yeah 15 minutes 15 minutes 15 and out
boom mix himself like a cat
[Laughter]
cough up a hairball and leave
ready night i was like a firefighter i i
didn't shower but i was on the couch
with with
liv and and liz called she goes 6 18 she
goes can you um see the seven o'clock i
go i'll be back in front actually dude i
was like a firefighter i got up i
grabbed my coat put it on kiss a wife
goodbye i'm out the door took her car
got there in 18 minutes gotta take it
and tell her
what i got a ticket didn't tell her
left the car got towed said it was
stolen
i've never even
[Laughter]
your windshield was all smashed in yeah
well i i it was like this when i got it
what kind of car does she have
honda blue electric blue real nice
electric blue yeah type in electric blue
look at that color that's a nice color
what are we doing no don't type that
it's got to be working a1
we can look up sid boards but we can't
look up a color are you kidding me
serious problem hey it's my show
hey you get a popular show you can do
what you want
but until then i'm in charge of the
google oh my gosh there'll be no
electric blue
electric blue it's kind of like this
this color right here
nice nice that's a nice flannel thanks
you selling it
[Laughter]
trading ahead
uh all right let's see here
hold on back to that quit that's insane
my shoes don't
we're we're pretty much in no shoes in
the house yeah but in the apartment
especially in new york you dude yeah you
can't walk into a [ __ ] bathroom with
your shoes on no because if there's any
water on the floor there's gonna be like
disgusting yeah that's the big thing
crazy dude the best i tell you is having
a mat next to the door with your shoes
so outside your shoes uh we have it
inside but we haven't yeah of course we
have that
and you put your slippers on there so
you do the transition oh so it's like
you wear the slippers to the door lee
park them there
yeah come back yep slip into something
the shoes outside's no good no no no
speaking of shoes
i would love to have you all over for
dinner one night we could thank you for
dinner yeah what is penny alabaca
bring your own pennies we're getting a
new couch so there's more room for
others
that'll be delivered on the day that we
get there that's nice can you guys help
us move this section the one on the
first floor yeah i have been mm-hmm
i've been here and you have that whole
place now yeah it's pretty nice it's
real nice we went to comedy that was the
day after my big television day yeah i
remember you go can you introduce i was
the first one to intro you on stage uh
with a tv credit yes i remember that
bristol comedy
gotham comedy live gotham comedy live
yes we all got that yeah
and i remember taking a piss on the side
of the road and derek had to hold my dog
in the front seat yeah yeah yeah he was
just a man brought your dog to his show
are you joan rivers
[ __ ] why did i drop her off in my mom's
afterwards comedy works was like i don't
know 45 minutes outside of delaware i
that show was me you derek cotton
dave
i forget and that's it yeah man yeah i
got it oh we thought we were doing it i
was on channel 837 one thousand at the
birth i was at your jeans in bristol the
next night yeah put out a nice plate of
pasta yeah they did they charged you for
though the next night i love a chicken
parm the next night on the way home i
made a pit stop to see rachel starr at
the local strip club
who's rachel starr you don't know rachel
starr she's a novelist who the [ __ ] do
you think she is
yeah yeah she's a poet laureate you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and went to a poetry reading in bristol
pa and [ __ ] 2 a.m no uh what's the
one in bristol the show
i don't know the [ __ ] club risque
don't go back i think they were clever
club you're making a mistake when you
give them fake money yeah they usually
yeah yeah
you can get a lap dance for a title loan
payday loans
uh all right this one's from johnny c
never had never had one red is it
garbage c
is it garbage to have a picture of
myself
kippy and foley in my dating app
profiles to make myself look slimmer pro
move my man carry on smart moves yeah
yes that is not garbage that is not
trash i like it
yeah it's also a little bit of star
power too we can we can [ __ ] help
nudge you along there you go is that
more likely nobody uses you in a dating
profile and then people recognize you
it's like an intro yeah that's pretty
neat yeah yeah pretty cool it's fun
what's yours you and lenny here it comes
here it comes yeah i helped lenny get
late
i knocked them down together all right
we got a couple more to do just to get
some of the first timers out of the way
um
all right this one's from andrew have
you ever handed out a business card with
a handwritten edit like here's my card
but this is the correct email wow no but
i've gotten them
you know who you know who get the [ __ ] i
don't use that number anymore here let
me right yeah let me give you let me
give you a direct line
you know who the first time i it was
even worse than a handwritten edit uh
to rest in peace our boy chris cotton
handed flip
a card that was it was two business
cards and he had them stapled to each
other and he's like yeah use the
information on the back that's the real
stuff i was like oh my god
what a bozo god bless a stapled staple
you ever get a bit like a headshot
resume stapled together it was like
chris it was like chris who called chris
cotton here's the thing whatever and
then he had like more updated
information or something so we had that
staple like
it was like a baseball card oh my god
[Laughter]
a piece of gummy i did not close the
deal i might have i
got traded
did you uh
have you ever gotten a business card
from someone that's like
paper oh yeah like they didn't spring
for like that yeah they've printed a
bunch out and they've cut it themselves
yeah i don't think i've ever got hands
in the business i got i was just i have
them and of all the shitty comics i have
them in the past uh
for whatever reason whenever i so you
know the past 10 years or however long i
had the montego the whole time was in
comedy i had my that car so i would just
keep them in the car and i just when i
sold it i went through dude it's just
like oh my god i wish they would come
back i like a business it's a real who's
who a bozo yeah oh yeah we should all be
handing each other business card like
gentlemen
and ladies it's classy we should get
back to that i've done them after shows
at the comedy cabaret of the northeast
oh dude the business card holy nobody
nobody wants to take something physical
that they got to put somewhere and
nobody is looking at a card and then
transferring that information to
whatever you're like i see i see like
things on instagram where it's like your
phone like you like pull something yeah
you go here and then it automatically
downloads your contact yeah yeah
that's the way to go but i've had some
cool ass business cards dude one of them
was me in in like a top hat that said in
finance prankster yeah
prankster chortles jokes and more
i dude i was
i leave off the last number in my phone
number got to make them work for it i
was uh
i was laying on the cover of my on the
hood of my camry in like a 70s suit with
platforms i remember that yeah that's a
good card you were walking like willy
wonka for like two years i remember that
you had the ruffles and the hat and all
that stuff that was nice yeah you stunk
those were the years i stayed away from
you
i did stink
i'll be the first one i met i do stink
dead
dick all right dead sorry
i do not deny that i did stink yeah yeah
and still do i may or may not still
stick
that is up for debate
um
uh this one's from burana uh timely is
it garbage to gift wrap the amazon boxes
a gift came in instead of taking that
item out my friend's point i just did it
my friend's boyfriend did this and i say
it's straight trash now she's
as she's unwrapping she has to open two
boxes that's fun no yes no it builds
excitement
that's crazy it's fun and also the box
is a template for the thing you need to
open so what are you gonna do you get a
pair of slippers you you wrap the
slippers no you have the box it comes in
i see what you're saying but like a lot
of times it's some up it comes in a box
like the package the product package if
you order a camera it's in that right
take that out of the amazon right right
i see what you're saying yeah yeah it's
just that yeah people aren't on loose
slippers on amazon
speak for yourself
buy one from here
i just need a left so i did i don't want
people to piece back together
i don't think that's that bad no no no
no yeah you don't open it up and that's
amazing you don't want to open it up and
have their shipping information on the
front that's a ban you want to open up
the you want to open up the wrapping
paper nobody can see that
nobody's expecting the box it's a fun
bit suspenseful build up to the gift no
it's a trash move now
the lazy trash i like the excitement
yeah for me the action is the juice me
too the more to open the better better
chime in
gave us our gift in the amazon boxes no
rapping by the way it's about the
journey not the destination yeah it's
the total garbage move i mean it's it's
one step above the bag with the f with
the fluffy paper on that's not trash are
you [ __ ] talking about that's my
go-to move that's the go-to movie
because it's lazy and trash no it's not
it's not it looks very nice and it's
nice to get a bag
you got something to carry it's a gift
100 times easier that's why you do it
yeah it's not because of that
because something is easy doesn't make
it trash that's nice if anything it
makes it gold because it seems you're
thinking ahead because you can kind of
see it there's never enough paper it's a
trash movie it's never enough paper
because you're [ __ ] trashy and you
don't buy enough paper no you're what
you didn't even bring a gift i left it
at home yeah that's what that means
what's the next question
now
wrap chocolates
i do i give out gifts to all my little
neighborhood shops you know what's real
nice maybe just the top box wrapped and
you lift that like it's like a shirt box
you lift that up oh that's oh
that's like
that's massive yeah that's real nice
what about this this is the most garbage
move ever
uh
like i i've seen this and i think it's
so [ __ ] up where parents will wrap a
ps5 box
the kid opens it and then there's like
socks or something
yeah did that no because we had opened
our presents we just we just talked
about this we opened all our presents
before christmas and i got a sega she
put dirty laundry in the sega and had me
open it up
did you ever get the sega
a couple hours later
after they just sweat it
oh that's fun that was their biggest
mistake because i put the freak out in
freak out
i burnt the house down
i murdered my parents you want to play
ball huh patty okay cool no way you
freaked out i got nothing to do for the
next eight hours how old were you
school's off all week you're lost yeah
how old were you you're gonna pay for
that lady i'll tell you that how old
were you i was like [ __ ] eleven or
twelve and you lost it oh man i did
everything what what it was like it was
like i was like deer hunter
[ __ ]
acted crazy cried said i was leaving i
was gonna kill myself
oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah she wants to [ __ ] we're
gonna start pulling that [ __ ] she wants
to get machiavelli and i could get
[ __ ] machiavelli said you were gonna
kill yourself on christmas
he's got a nerf gun
i'll do it i'll do it you dumb [ __ ]
i'll do it is this what you want huh
where the [ __ ] the sonic kick
i'm holding a dog in front of me
taking hostages
man me and bugs are going down together
i'll [ __ ] kill them i swear
oh my god these are the rubber tips too
you know what i heard
yeah you stink dude you're nuts you're
crazy
i totally understand lunatic you asked
me a question i'm just trying to be
honest
i'll throw these brass shoes out in a
heartbeat
bronze brass these aluminum foiled shoes
out right away
reynolds wrap that's the good stuff
that's what she used
well looks like leftovers
she put a little swan head on it ollie
christmas dinner right well your father
your left foot so uh
let's do another one
this one's from chris did you know
anyone who claimed their dog was part
wolf
dude every dirtbag kid that lived too
close to the woods always said that oh
that's a [ __ ]
home
hey he's you know he's 14 wolf okay
you're 100 douche kick rocks
no one's buying that
it's a
beagle it's a pomeranian
oh
it's a cat
jesus christ
let's wrap that up that's [ __ ] crazy
ah
[Laughter]
he goes out there every night to do it
you throw everybody off
he's doing it out of the side of his
mouth hey guys you know don't show any
silver to my dog
it's a full moon i better get rusty
inside
gang we love you ian what do you got
coming up here once the folks start
today oh my god what scam are you
pulling that
it's all in the licenses
what's the next heist
i if you guys want to buy some of my
merch
send me 300 bucks i will send you back a
hundred and
i animal 69 on instagram twitter and
twitch uh i have uh laughing up
poughkeepsie coming up february 11th and
12th
uh diego made a killer poster i'm very
happy about that right vermont comedy
club coming up uh doing a weekend there
that'll be fun uh next week i'm going to
be in connecticut rhode island and maine
there you go
there you go
go see the fellas i got some other stuff
coming out it's going to be it's going
to be a fun year it's going to be fun
very exciting very special this year wow
[ __ ] oh wait nice well yes you know
we love you to death and uh i love you
we're glad that we got you do you give
it to come back you know the holidays
and stuff like that it's great to see
you and we love you you too you guys are
my brothers and i'll murder someone for
you
okay
jesus christ toby watch your back give
me what are you guys gonna be no
autograph signing after this uh guy
you just dalton the [ __ ] out of that
wacko
[ __ ] we're not smoking a cig after
this you're my best
you gotta stand across the street
you're my best friends and i'll kill
anybody who says otherwise
including you
if you don't return my call or book
lenny dykstra i'll kill you
oh you didn't wish me happy birthday did
ya
you turn around she says dijkstra on the
back he turns around real slow
i told you i could do the show call me
nails here i'll kill you
uh guys check out the uh check out the
special check out
it's uh very good thank you very much we
appreciate it the 2022 tour we are about
to announce next week after this comes
that week a couple days after this comes
out lining all that up we [ __ ]
appreciate it uh yeah guys who [ __ ]
love you looking forward to 2022 happy
new year love yous see you soon